hi I'm Jonathan Wright owner of the
punchbowl where we make the world's best
hangover smoothie and I'm about to show
you how to make one the ingredients have
the lovely hangover smoothie we have
here at the punch bowl our mango
pineapple both frozen is you don't want
to add ice to a smoothie coconut water
which is lovely it's very hydrating
nature's skater in this and coconut meat
give that fattiness in there a dash of
activated charcoal lovely thing that
lines through the toxins and
pharmaceuticals in our body and helps
flush them out turmeric great for
headaches muscle cramps
anti-inflammatory and coconut nectar
which is a sweetener derived from the
coconut blossom Laura glycemic so
doesn't give you a giant boost of and
drop you um it's very important though
that all these are organic is that
they're not the side effects could be
definitely I worked in bars in New York
for a long long time and we used to have
these bar challenges where we mean the
other bartenders would see how much
booze we could drink in the night and we
would challenge each other literally I
was there to 4:00 a.m. and I hadn't go
to work at 8 a.m. so I had about two
hours of sleep after that horrible job
and I went into work and I was like you
know I'm just gonna try to make the best
thing I can make for myself and I made
it and I felt slightly better just like
which is a huge improvement considering
the way I felt
for more hangover cures and our grades
on them subscribe to the channel and
like us oh yes you deserve to be like
yeah we